bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir le
coronavirus venus de chine l'évacuation
des étrangers s'organise sur fond de
critiques sur le manque de transparence
de pékin un premier cas de contamination
entre humains a été signalé sur le sol
européen en allemagne et la situation en
france est elle sous contrôle cette
crise sanitaire est elle bien gérée
alors qu'on apprend un quatrième cas
dans notre pays
on en débat ce soir avec nos invités
après la rue après les syndicats la
guérilla sur les retraites devient
parlementaires de droite de gauche les
oppositions tire à boulet rouge contre
le passage en force du gouvernement le
conseil d'état avait déjà alerté sur les
risques de précipitations à ce que la
majorité pourra rester sourde à toutes
ces critiques
on en débat ce soir sur ce plateau et
puis notre grand témoin ce soir est une
plume mais aussi une voix dans le débat
d'idées depuis des années il est
journaliste il est patron pressé il
revient avec un livre anne armand sur
nos erreurs
à l'origine de la montée en flèche de
marine le pen jean françois kahn est
avec nous ce soir voilà vous savez tout
ces partis hashtag sévère n'oubliez pas
au liban
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir jean
françois kahn bonsoir et merci d'être
notre grand témoin on a une heure à
passer ensemble journaliste fondateur de
plusieurs journaux journaux dit vous
n'êtes tout journaliste un peu quand
même
non c'est terminé vous écrivez encore
des livres et parfois des articles de
presse dans marianne notamment vous
publiez droit dans le mur point
d'exclamation chez plon le mur c'est
celui dans lequel on fonce si on ne se
penche pas sérieusement dit vous sur nos
erreurs celle de la gauche celle de la
droite celle des médias
nos erreurs en somme collective
sociétale on est à deux ans et demi de
la présidentielle
et on va essayer de savoir s'il nous
reste une chance ou pas avant ce mur on
en parlera un peu plus tard dans
l'émission mais d'abord on va commencer
avec l'actualité et l'actualité c'est
toujours ce coronavirus venus de chine
des chiffres sont impressionnants plus
de 4000 personnes atteintes
principalement dans la province d'omrane
107 morts tous en chine plus de 50
millions de personnes confinées quatre
cas seulement en france
un nouveau cas un qui s'ajoute ce soir
on en parle avec vous a ajouté bonsoir
et merci d'être là d'être député la
république en marche des français d'asie
vous êtes médecin consultant en risques
sanitaires liés au risque pandémique
antoine bondage bonsoir vous enseigne à
sion ce pauvre d'être chercheur à la
fondation pour la recherche stratégique
et vous êtes spécialiste de la chine
bienvenus eric dor thank you bonsoir
merci d'être là vous êtes médecin
épidémiologiste chercheur à l'inserm et
spécialiste les crises sanitaires dus
aux maladies infectieuses émergentes je
vous donne la parole à tous les quatre
dans un instant mais celui qui va ouvrir
ce premier débat avec sa plume avec son
ton et son regard c'est stéphane les
fans blakowski c'est parti
[Musique]
myriam ont souffert certains messieurs
alors si j'ai bien compris ce soir si
j'ai bien compris à myriam en ce moment
en france il ya un truc qui se propage
encore plus vite que le coran la virus
c'est la peur du cornet virus
parce que bon faut dire que la peur ce
cas extrêmement contagieux comme émotion
quand tout le monde panique beaucoup de
remous extrêmement difficile de rester
calme comme l' orchestre du titanic qui
jouait calmement pendant que le navire
des trams cendres et ça c'est quasiment
impossible
vous exigez un peu là on n'est quand
même pas sur le titanic alors j'avoue
myriam au nom n'est pas encore à se
battre pour avoir des places dans les
canots de sauvetage
mais enfin bon v remarquer qu'il ya déjà
une pénurie sont des masques anti grippe
qui sait si on se mettra pas des coups
de coude bientôt dans les pharmacies
pour avoir accès aux vaccins avant les
autres à kadam un petit frisson
d'inquiétude qui passe dans le pays un
dans le métro ce matin et je faisais
quelqu'un éternue pour que tout le monde
se dit moi je quitte le wagon je ne
quitte pas même la presse en parle cette
inquiétude regarder ce week-end le
parisien nous dit samedi
faut-il avoir peur du chrono virus et le
lendemain le parisien répond à la
question qu'il a lui même posé la veille
redore pas de panique donc sa forme deux
jours le parisien quand même réussi à
mettre peur et panique à la une à dix
ans a bien sûr qu'il faut pas avoir peur
il faut pas paniquer enfin on s'inquiète
un peu sinon pourquoi on ferait des
débats sur lcp sur le corps d'un virus
il faut quand même rappeler que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
affirme qu'il à risque élevé que
l'épidémie qui donc a commencé en chine
et bien s'étendre au monde entier alors
c'est vrai il ya un risque élevé pas
très élevé mais élever mon bois que
l'épidémie se propage rapidement en
chine qui a quatre cas de gens
contaminés en france dont heureusement
pour l'instant pas de victimes
en même temps j'ai lu ce matin que le
taux de mortalité du virus était 3% donc
la majorité l'immense même majorité des
gens a priori touché par le virus
a lens on devrait s'en sortir du coup
sans vouloir non plus minimiser la
menace du corps un avis russe mettant
d'un coup de la place quand même de
s'apprend dans les médias parce que dans
les médias il ya une loi officieuse un
peu cynique que connaît forcément jean
françois kahn qu'on appelle la loi du
maure km pour résumer tout le monde la
connaît sait pas c'est que s'il ya un
accident d'autocar en inde qui fait 30
morts évidemment que ça prendra beaucoup
beaucoup moins de place dans nos
journaux que si un autocar dérape en
france et que ça fait trente mans où on
a compris ce système or le corps navires
us co
ce correspond pas à cette règle il ya
aucune victime en france et pourtant on
en parle beaucoup plus de la grippe par
exemple qui l'an dernier a fait plus de
8000 morts c'est ce que dit en tout cas
santé publique car comment vous
l'expliquez ça alors en tant que
journaliste je dois avouer que
journaliste on a tendance à présenter à
leurs lecteurs à leurs auditeurs à leurs
téléspectateurs
des histoires qui les intéressent et
alors là en vieux routier des médias pas
comme jean françois kahn mais une petite
expérience je peux vous dire que les
risques d'épidémies d'épidémie mondiale
c'est même beaucoup plus vendeur que les
méfaits de la fibre dans les ehpad alors
pour vous donner un avis c'est pas moi
qui le pense
regardez les grands films qui ont été
faits sur le sujet des épidémies il ya
même un genre film catastrophe
épidémiologique donc alerte qu'on voit
ici avec dustin hoffman
il ya contagion le film de soderbergh
est à 28 jours le film de danny boyle
donc voyez des films sur les méfaits de
la crypte dans les ehpad en revanche on
a très très peu de frais bah oui ou
doute parce que ça remplirait pas les
salles enfin moi c'est mon opinion sur
les films et ben je me demanderais
figurez-vous si on ne joue pas ça parce
que la peur n'est pas forcément bon de
conseil en souvient qu'en 2010 un
exemple bien au mois d'octobre le la
cour des comptes avait été on va dire
très sévère avec roselyne bachelot qui
accueille reproché d'avoir commandé
beaucoup trop de vaccins contre le h1n1
alors que c'était pas vraiment
nécessaire d'en du coup aujourd'hui à
grammont le gouvernement ne s'affole pas
c'est moi ça m'a frappée parce qu'entre
nous si par hasard par hasard l'épidémie
avait été plus forte et qu'il avait
manqué de vaccins
qu'est-ce qu'elle aurait prix exact ces
exemples de précaution finalement
qu'elle l'a choisi il a exposé un autre
reproche donc ben alors il vaut mieux je
suis là quand même
en tout cas le gouvernement aujourd'hui
ne s'affole pas et la preuve si ben dhia
il me rassurait hier matin montant des
choses qui sont extrêmement inquiétantes
moi je comprends parfaitement que bon
nombre de nos concitoyens se posent des
questions mais je veux à ce micro les
rassurer très largement parce que à ce
stade la situation est parfaitement sous
contrôle
alors puisque tout est sous contrôle
pourquoi s'inquiéter eh ben on est là
pour en débattre
eh ben on y va ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses déjà dans votre pc et stéphane on
va tout simplement commencer par cette
question est ce qu'on en fait trop est
ce que les médias en font trop sur ce qu
en amérique au fond vous vraiment là
il ya des raisons de s'inquiéter de
s'interroger ce qui est toujours
difficile de savoir où on met le curseur
il faut quand même informé apporter de
l'information mais qui effectivement
vous l'avais dit dans votre papier
transmet forcément un peu d'inquiétude
et qui peut devient de l'angoissé chez
certains c'est regrettable mais il faut
quand même transmettre une information
aujourd'hui l'information de base c'est
lavez vous les mains
tous ont la meilleure manière contre il
faut le dire on a bien vu c'est normal
d'un seul coup lavez vous les mains sans
expliquer pourquoi ils vont nous on
vient même temps quand on voit de la
ministre de la santé parle tous les
jours qu'on centre quasiment toute la
parole ça change un petit peu un mais
jusqu'à présent il n'y avait qu'elle qui
parlait est ce que ça donne pas le
sentiment que la communication est un
peu verrouillé exercer leur audience de
la santé quand même d'organiser deux
moniteurs et de surveiller par dans
l'évolution de la maladie de préparer
d'anticiper on est obligé d'anticiper
pour une situation qu'on ne connaît pas
est ce qu'on va évoluer vers une
infection qui se tarit et disparaît tout
seul où est ce qu'on va évoluer vers
quelque chose qui s'emballe on ne sait
pas ça nécessite de prendre des
précautions de s'organiser
il faut quand même saluer le fait qu'on
est très bien organisé bien organisé le
centre 15 ne pas aller aux urgences on
rappelle les consignes la ministre
explique qu on traite ce genre
d'épidémie comme un incendie il faut
éviter qu'il ne se propage mais est-ce
qu'on a les moyens de stopper la
contagion en france dans un dans un pays
ouvert une économie ouverte comme le
stopper la contagion s'est aussi
l'action de chacun au quotidien c'est
vraiment se laver les mains quand on
commence à voir quelques symptômes et ce
qu'il compte il a d'ailleurs pour cette
épidémie les à la vôtre est aussi pour
d'autres épidémies je rappelle qu'en ce
moment on est quand même en période
d'épidémie de grippe qui est en train de
monter qui n'a pas encore atteint son
pic et qui est quand même qu'ils
voulaient rappeler le bilan 2008-2009
ses 8000 morts le bilan 2017 2018 donc
toujours santé publique 7 13 mille morts
pour la grippe donc on parle de chiffres
qui dépassent par mme largement les
vagues les dents et pour la grippe là
aussi des précautions à prendre quand on
commence à voir des symptômes
on y en a des personnes qui vont prendre
un anti fièvre et puis qui vous quand
même aller travailler qui vont quand
même avec leurs enfants à l'école et je
rappelle que les enfants sont les
premiers vecteurs de la bpm grippe au
départ novo le message de l'état est
organisée on surveille et on vous donne
les consignes qu'on vous demande de
respecter le plus possible lavez vous
les mains et nommé vous mettez pas en
contact avec de la population encore qui
plus une population fragile on va pas
voir sa grand mère quand on commence à
tousser alors dernière peut-être
question quand vous dites
enfin quand les pouvoirs publics
expliquent qu'ils vont remonter les
entourages c'est à dire qu'on a quatre
cas et s'auto résultats dans l'assurance
d'une déliquescence à un non non non non
on a des bons outils
on dit pas que c'est exhaustif et qu'on
est parfait mais c'est nécessaire
d'aller le rechercher ce qu'on appelle
les cas contacts c'est à dire demandez
aux gens qui avez vous rencontré et puis
dans quelles circonstances vous l'avez
rencontré entre une personne que vous
avez croisé à trois mètres dans la rue
ou une personne avec qui vous avez
échangé un long dialogue serré les mains
et passer du temps voilà on va évaluer
achats car on s'est fait la compta mais
bien sûr mais on n'est pas faux faut pas
croire qu'on va absolument scanner 100 %
de la population mais en tout cas c'est
un outil efficace de recherche des cas
possibles alors je vous retourne vers
l'épidémiologiste que vous êtes on va
essayer de comprendre un peu plus sur ce
virus que c'est tout précisément à
l'heure où on se parle sur ce virus
alors on en sait beaucoup plus qu'il ya
quinze jours trois semaines on en a
appris beaucoup en temps réel donc on
sait que c'est parti donc d'une
d'une ville qui s'appelle ou one que les
premiers cas ont fréquenté un marché qui
est un marché aux poissons aux fruits de
mer mais on sait que dans ce marché sont
vendus également des animaux vivants et
morts
donc ça c'est une chose on est en train
de remonter la source du virus pour
savoir quel animal a transmis le virus
la première fois à l'homme ça on ne le
sait pas hélas race est un animal qui
s'appelait la civelle c'était la civette
palmer qui était l'autre intermédiaire
qui avait transmis le virus à des
conflits internes et or une autre
responsable
alors la source et la dangerosité qu'est
ce qu'on sait sur la dangerosité
ce n'est pas 10 et 3 % de mortalité des
stable se chient l'heure actuelle il est
autour de 3 % il est assez stable depuis
quelques jours depuis qu'on a des
données sérieuses qui nous remontent de
la chine
on est à 4400 cas ce soir et une
centaine de décès donc le chiffre de 3 %
il est le même que hier pour comparaison
le strass étaient 10%
on est sur un maladie un peu moins
sévère que le strass comparaison avec la
grippe vous donniez des chiffres en
valeur absolue mais la mortalité de la
grippe c'est un pour mille en général
donc on est quand même un peu supérieur
à la grippe saisonnière
ce qu'on sait c'est que les personnes
qui sont décédées et celles qui ont des
cas sévères sont plutôt des personnes
avec un âge avancé avec une pathologie
sous jacente type diabète insuffisance
respiratoire
un peu comme la grippe normale et sur la
transmission
parce qu'on apprend aujourd'hui que il
ya une première transmission d'humain à
humain sans que forcément ce soit une
personne atteinte venus de chine c'est
ça alors sur la transmission ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on allemagne oui ce qu'on
sait c'est que donc il la transmission
interhumaine est avérée elle est plutôt
plutôt bien soutenu ce qu'on sait pas
c'est si la transmission peut se faire
au moment de la période d'incubation il
ya des peintres qui dure alors entre 2
et 10 11 jours en moyenne six jours
c'est avec les données actuelles ce
qu'on sait pas c'est si c'est contagieux
pendant la période d'incubation et ça ça
va être déterminant parce que si c'est
le cas c'est vrai que la transmission se
fait beaucoup plus
rapidement est ce qu'on appelle les
mesures barrières pour les périodes
ignore exactement peuvent contaminer les
autres
quand on voit que les les masques sont
en rupture de stock c'est efficace le
masque alors le masque il est efficace
pour les personnes malades c'est à dire
que c'est une mesure barrière pour le
patient malade ça va empêcher les
gouttelettes de se projeter et donc
voilà mais par contre une personne
malade ça sert à rien non ah bon moi je
la prends alors y avoir beaucoup de gens
qui me protège comme le débat
non mais je sais c'est rien fait pour
pour les soignants est quand même
recommandé c'est ma manette et qui
étaient un peu inquiets ne pas avoir de
masque en fait non seulement c'est un
autre type de match on appelle ffp2
online 95 c'est pas du tout le masque
chirurgical classique
ça c'est pour les soignants ceux qui
sont en contact avec les malades qui les
prennent en charge
pour la protection divine je continue
mes questions parce que je pense qu'il
faut de l'information puis on fera
circuler la parole
la mutation du virus elle est possible
vers quoi quelles sont les pistes elle
elle est possible elle a déjà eu lieu
probablement entre l'animal et l'homme
puisque c'est une barrière d'espèce donc
c'est un virus qui normalement n'est pas
présent chez l'homme c'est ça circule
souvent chez les chauves souris pour le
ce qui concerne les coronavirus un autre
intermédiaire un animal qu'on ne connaît
pas encore là il ya déjà une mutation et
après quand ces transmissions
interhumaines
à chaque fois que le virus se réplique
dans le corps il y a des petites
modifications mais pas assez pour dire
qu'il ya une médiation qui le remplit
peut devenir plus dangereux ou moins
dangereux c'est ça voilà il pourrait
dans les deux sens en fait
l'alimentation et ça on le saura quand
on surveille en fait les la question des
les chercheurs qui font des diagnostics
maintenant dépose les séquences des
virus sur un site en ligne et elles sont
comparées en temps réel donc on verra à
un moment donné si les nouvelles
séquences diagnostiqués sont différentes
des premières et on pourrait dire là il
ya une mutation majeure ou pas ça qu'il
faut de la surveillance extrême s élève
son niveau d alerte
ça change quoi concrètement il ya des
concertations possible en 3d et à iliad
et il ya surtout que l'aloe metz prend
la coordination il va émettre des
recommandations aux pays membres
l'om est c'est à dire que si à un moment
donné il va falloir donner des
recommandations fortes pour les
contrôles aux frontières ou des
contrôles quoi que ce soit c'est là où
ça devient important et intéressant
c'est à dire que c'est une façon d'avoir
un sale politique mondiale politique
coordonnée internationale alors on va
parler de la chine avec vous parce que
là une question que l'on pourrait
qualifier un vaccin on bosse déjà sur un
axe nissan a pas de 6,6 en position
d'avoir sur des vaccins on travaille sur
des traitements il ya déjà des choses
qui sont lancés en chine est une des
molécules qui sont évalués en temps réel
pendant l'épidémie et des vaccins des
laboratoires qui ont lancé des
recherches sur les vaccins en
repositionnant certains vaccins qui
était avancé sur le maire ce coronavirus
et le fait qu'on ait le test nous en
france plutôt que les autres c'est pour
ça qu'on sait qu'on a des cas les autres
n'ont pas tout tout tout tout les pays
européens angleterre où il un champ je
peux pas vous l'affirmez en tout cas
c'est allé vite là je pense que les pays
vont l'avoir dans les jours qui viennent
si alors pas de panique en france en
revanche c'est la psychose en chine on
al'impression vraiment que la population
vit un cauchemar c'est la panique pour
plusieurs raisons premièrement la
dispersion du virus qui est extrêmement
importante nous avons ce soir l'ensemble
des provinces de chine à l'exception du
tibet qui sont affectés mais ce qui est
plus inquiétant c'est qu'au sein des
différentes provinces de chine
ce sont de nombreuses villes qui sont
touchés donc ce n'est pas localisée dans
par exemple le chef-lieu où les plus
grandes villes des provinces c'est dans
l'ensemble du territoire chinois y
compris dans les camps par garder une
carte le traitement que ce sont des
centaines d'hôpitaux qui aujourd'hui en
chine doit faire face à ce virus
deuxièmement il ya des mesures
extrêmement fortes qui ont été prises et
mises en oeuvre par parle par le pouvoir
chinois et par le parti puisque le parti
ce soir à la coordination de la réponse
à l'épidémie le premier ministre chinois
li keqiang est notamment chargé de cette
coordination
les mesures sont majeurs donc mise en
quarantaine de quasiment 60 millions de
personnes fassent dans la province
exactement duroux paye mais ce n'est ce
ne sont que les premières meilleur 400
millions de chinois doivent durer
combien la messe qui est extrêmement
important c'est que vous avez
aujourd'hui les écoles qui ne seront pas
rouvertes dans les jours qui viennent
vous avez les lieux publics qui sont
interdits de rassemblement en
signe dans l'ensemble de la chine vous
avez quasiment l'ensemble des provinces
qui ont mise en oeuvre un plan d'urgence
sanitaire de niveau 1
ce sont des mesures extrêmement sérieuse
amour and précisément il y a des
chiffres qui sont inquiétants puisque si
on se concentre sur le nombre de cas
déclarés et le nombre de morts
uniquement dans la ville de wuhan et
avant que le virus se propage on a un
taux de mortalité de 5 à 10%
est ce que les chiffres que l'on a on va
voir sur la carte donne à l'image de
l'ensemble de la chaussée des chiffres
de la chine justement uniquement à leur
alliance 4409 personnes atteintes 107
morts tous en chine je parle sous
contrôle pourrait être sous-estimée pour
deux raisons premièrement parce que le
parti souhaite retenir une partie des
informations c'est possible mais aussi
puisque les cas n'ont pas encore été
détectée ça c'est une autre chose encore
une fois quand vous avez des centaines
d'hôpitaux sur l'ensemble du territoire
chinois c'est la taille de l'ofppt qui
doivent réaliser des tests c'est
compliqué en terme de logistique ce qui
explique notamment que l'armée a été
mobilisée ya quelques jours notamment ce
qu'on appelle le département de soutien
logistique dont l'objectif est notamment
d'acheminer des équipements au coeur du
web
système de reconnaissance faciale qui
s'installe en chine qui permet d
identifier
peut-être pas tous les citoyens mais une
grande partie est ce qu'on peut est ce
que ça peut être utilisés pour repérer
tous les gens de cette ville qui se sont
éparpillés dans le pays les retrouver en
face on leur voiture leur schéma qu un
téléphone lors
alors pour l'instant ça ne fonctionne
pas il y à des portails thermique qui
vont être installés dans les gares qui
sont encore ouvertes même si encore une
fois nombreuses gares dans la province
du hubei sont fermés les routes entre
les différentes provinces sont en cours
de fermeture pour limiter les
déplacements dans l'ensemble de la chine
et puis encore une fois on a des
annonces extrêmement récente qui sont
inquiétantes d'arrivée de one
par exemple la ville de wuhan vient
d'annoncer que les crémations ont été
rendues gratuites dans la ville que les
procédures de crémation était accéléré
et que des flottes par exemple
d'équipements et de moyens les inquiète
à nouveau média pas de masque alors en
france il n'y a pas d'épidémie pour
l'instant fait à montclair mais la
situation en chine est extrêmement
préoccupante ce n'est que le début et
les ip des murs l'egypte notamment à
hong kong qui sont réputés pour être
extrêmement sérieux notamment les
équipes de gabriel longue considère que
ce soit par exemple il pourrait y avoir
en cas réels n'ont pas les cas déclarés
bancarel jusqu'à 40000 personnes par
exemple êtes d'accord avec ce constat là
c'est très préoccupant la situation en
chine
disons que le lait sur la modélisation
qui a été annoncée la ces jours-ci de
l'équipe de hong kong
il faut il faut prendre avec modération
il faut bien regarder les chiffres
c'est sûr qu'il ya probablement plus de
cas que ce qu'on a ce soir être 1904 le
temps que ce soit détectée confirmé et
c'est sur la modélisation voilà il faut
prendre avec des pincettes ça a parfois
des effets annonce pour provoquer une
mobilisation scientifique internationale
donc ça peut avoir du bon aussi parce
qu'on a des chiffres très
impressionnants et de travail des
syndiqués différent de l'épisode du sras
ce que précédent où on apprécie que
l'information circule mieux ça va plus
vite
clairement oui on est on est plus
transparent en tout cas les chinois sont
plus transparents sur le début de
l'épidémie il ya une meilleure
préparation de la communauté
scientifique
on a beaucoup appris des épidémies
ultérieure strass
merce ebola la recherche met en place
beaucoup plus rapidement pour évaluer
des diagnostics des traitements des
vaccins donc c'est sûr qu'il ya une
expérience acquise sur cela on y est
donc des gains d'information de
procédures de savoir faire et en même
temps il ya aussi déjà des critiques sur
le manque de transparence de pékin
notamment si j'ai bien préparé cette
émission-là alerte sur la dangerosité a
été donnée quatre jours avant le nouvel
an les vacances et la mise en
quarantaine de branne a été faite juste
la veille et on a su depuis dimanche le
maire de la ville a expliqué que 5
millions d'habitants était parti dans
ces trois jours d'intervalle 5 millions
en portant potentiellement le virus dans
le pays
effectivement la réponse notamment sur
la scène internationale a été plus
rapide qu'en 2003 ça c'est sûr en 2003
il avait fallu attendre 18 morts la
propagation à hong kong pour que les
autorités chinoises contact l'om s et
internationaliste entre guillemets ya le
cas là on a eu un cas annoncé le 31
décembre
bien avant la mort du premier patient
puisqu'il est mort le 11 janvier par
contre pour l'instant il ya déjà des
incertitudes puisque le premier cas
peut-être aurait été comment ça aurait
été annoncée dès en fait la fin du mois
de novembre
les équipes de recherche chinoise en
réalité ont été mises sur notamment le
kit de détection
dès le mois de décembre et le maire de
mourom dans cette même reconnu qu'il
avait effectivement eu un retard à
l'allumage entre guillemets parce qu'il
n'avait pas reçu l'autorisation par
pékin de répondre c'est donc notamment
pour ça que chez jean ping ces derniers
jours s'est affichée pour montrer qu'il
était aux commandes et que le pays
vraiment non seulement était dans son
ensemble mobilisés alors il ya
évidemment sur les réseaux sociaux en
chine des inquiétudes pour l'instant n'y
a pas une remise en cause serait très
claire de la crédibilité du parti bien
ça commence on a aussi des cas
extrêmement préoccupant par des villages
qui se ferme là des villages qui
refusent que des étrangers entre
guillemets entre dans le village une
discrimination qui est fait par exemple
sur les personnes qui ont une voiture
immatriculée du roubaix où personne ne
veut les voir venir dans les villes la
ville de chongqing une ville de plus de
30 millions d'habitants pas si loin que
ça
burhan qui avait accueilli de nombreuses
personnes de one qui aujourd'hui se pose
des questions est ce qu'il aurait fallu
refuser d'accueillir c'est toutes les
mesures drastiques être prise plus tôt
et donc ça c'est des questions au niveau
est tellement micro niveau des familles
qui va se poser évidemment la question
évidemment aussi de l'évacuation des
ressortissants étrangers de l'instant il
n'y a pas de y'a pas de questions
politiques qui se posent à damgan nam
effet la chine encore vraiment au début
les gens parlent sur les réseaux sociaux
faut pas penser qu'en chine parce qu'il
ya une censure que personne ne peut
parler les gens parlent mais en tout cas
pour l'instant il n'y a pas une remise
en cause directe et qui pourrait menacer
le parti à très court terme jean
françois kahn qu'est-ce qu'il vous
inspire pardon once you à l'intérieur
très nettement axée sur les provinces
intérieures exactement parce que moi je
connais je connais groisne jeu j'ai été
si une ville incroyable c'est une ville
qu'on surnomme le chaudron de la chine
quand j'y étais j'ai cru parce qu'il ya
des usines métallurgiques
donc j'ai cru que c'était parce qu'il y
avait dit gilles métallurgique mais pas
du tout ce qui fait 44 degrés à l'ombre
et les gens dorment dehors que vous vous
enfin quand tu fait chaud moi je me suis
h sortie d'une un boulevard locaux plus
grands boulevards de wood mais sur des
kilomètres étaient des lits parce que
les gens sortent leur lit dans la rue et
dormait dans le lit ça n'a rien à voir
avec l'épidémie mais parle 2 2 c'est une
ville dure on touche là au mode de vie
chinois qui fait qu'effectivement on ne
vit pas comme nous chacun dans une
chambre séparée
voilà la façon de vivre aussi n'est pas
facile pour aider à contenir ce type
d'absolu mans alors on va revenir en
france et on sait que je suis j'espère
parce qu'on parlait tout à l'heure la
sphère bachelot pourrait parler aussi de
la canicule
le pauvre ministre de l'athéisme que
l'ama compter qu'on a désigné du doigt
parce qu'il avait un petit short
j'espère que cette fois on évitera les
polémiques inutiles
c'est vraiment un sentiment là parfois
crier viva a mis en garde m de santé à
la moindre épidémie tout qu'on se
précipite comme des chiens pour hacker
ce que je peux l'utiliser pour en faire
une polémique
soit une polémique sur les plateaux de
télé soit une polémique radio sur une
polémique politique
c'est insupportable qu'on essaye
d'éviter ça si par hasard
naturellement le
on a quelque chose en france qui
inquiète alors geste et dans le monde
politique vous entendre il inquiété
c'est notamment ce rapatriement des
ressortissants français étaient d'ordre
moral parce qu'ils sont nombreux et
parce que c'est c'est une sonde une
interrogation attendez on va regarder un
sujet d' hélène bonduelle puisque on a
ce premier rapatriement un badge la
différence on a pas cinquante la même
mesure rapatriement inquiète aujourd'hui
on sait comment il va se dérouler ce
rapatriement qui va monter à bord à tous
les moyens de prendre en charge les
quelques 800 ressortissants français qui
ont séjourné dans cette région de chine
les questions les réponses et celle du
gouvernement pour rassurer ses signée
hélène bonduelle images impressionnantes
des rues de hauranne quasi déserte plus
de 11 millions d'habitants totalement
coupés du monde
confinés chez eux parmi eux 500 à 1000
français expatriés ou en voyage dans la
région et beaucoup attendent d'être
rapatriés en france
c'est le cas de nicolas du et ses sept
collègues arrivés à houran le 20 janvier
pour travailler sur le chantier d'un
parc d'aventuré ils sont cloîtrés depuis
cinq jours dans leur hôtel un quotidien
pas vraiment rassurant pour ce français
qui a atterri en chine en pleine
épidémie a déjà vu plusieurs ambulances
voilà venir autour de nous avec des gens
habillés comme des cosmonautes tout ça
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas rassurant
le premier jour en fait nous servez avec
des gants et un masque et on a quand
même vu la cuisinière enlevé de masques
pour parler aux cuisiniers au dessus de
la nourriture serait que même quand on
en a contaminé comme ce à quoi les
hôpitaux apparemment sont vraiment des
bords dijon qu'une médicaments exemple
une masse comme un simple une tête de
guerre donc si c'est vraiment pas
rassurant il s'est inscrit sur la liste
des demandes de rapatriement et a
rapidement été contacté par le consulat
elles nous ont juste envoyer un papier
vous voilà avec une fiche médicale
savoir j'en avais des traitements tout
ça mais pour anticiper dans l'avion pour
qu'il connaisse au mieux le cas de
chaque personne
c'est vrai que c'est un soulagement nous
nos proches et votre sens est un excité
concernant le virus notre état de santé
savoir bout de combien de temps on
allait pouvoir partir un vol direct
partira demain pour anne et devraient
atterrir en france vendredi ou samedi
à son bord au moins 250 français et dans
la semaine un autre vol
patry rappelé deux cents ressortissants
de l'union européenne il ya aussi un
mécanisme européen qui va se mettre en
place pour assurer une bonne coopération
entre les différents états membres pour
permettre à ceux de nos compatriotes
européens qui voudraient rentrer de le
faire une équipe médicale accompagnera
les français rapatriés à bord de l'avion
nous sommes en constitution de l'équipe
médicale qui va accompagner cet avion
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir identifier
sur place il ya des personnes malades
pour qu'elle fasse l'objet d'une prise
en charge particulière et d'un transport
particulier arrivé en france les
rapatriés seront accueillis dans des
lieux d'hébergement à l'abri de tout
contact sous surveillance médicale et à
proximité d'un établissement de santé
l'objectif c'est que nous puissions
répondre aux inquiétudes répondre aux
éventuels symptômes cliniques
bénéficieront ensuite d'un suivi
personnalisé biquotidien médical pendant
14 jours pour éviter toute propagation
du virus
les personnes qui seraient testés
positifs au corona virus et donc malade
devrait être rapatrié dans un deuxième
temps pour éviter toute contamination et
placé en quarantaine dans des hôpitaux
français il est actuellement en france
36 unités de maladies infectieuses en
capacité de les accueillir à john thain
alors comment va se dérouler au fond ce
rapatriant ce rapatriement
d'abord 250 cessa français et les autres
c'est ce qui est dit alors d'abord il
faut savoir y avait des français qui
vivent là-bas sur place et moi j'ai été
contacté puisque c'est ma
circonscription par des français qui
m'ont dit non non moi je ne rentre pas
je dirige une équipe j'ai des chinois
employés par solidarité avec eux je ne
rentrerai pas mais je fais rentrer ma
femme seuls ceux qui veulent rentrer en
syrie l'horizon reçu du consulat un
email dont j'ai eu copie dimanche dans
deux week-ends dans lequel leur
demandait leur coordonnées leur état de
santé ouzou il se trouve pas ce qu'on a
dans le cas des festivités chinois
s'attendent de français qui résident sur
place
en fait était venue en france passer le
nouvel an chinois donc tous les gens qui
ont été contactés n'était pas forcément
il ya combien de français dans la région
rania combien de français en chine alors
en chine en tout ont compris trente
mille français qui vivent officiellement
il ya parfois des gens qui ne sont pas
enregistrés là je rappelle aussi
toujours que quand on va s'installer
quelque part on s'inscrit au consulat
quand on va voyager quelque part on sen
si on s'inscrit sur le site
ariane
la région est là parce qu'il ya les
roches y voilà les chiffres sur la
région de vannes sur la circonscription
rurale
on a à peu près 500 français qui y
vivent je pensais c'est à dire hommes
femmes et enfants et ensuite on a ceux
qui peuvent venir qui double zone ils
veulent revenir reviendront pousse alors
c'est ce qui est prévu
absolument c'est ce que lagarde avait
causé les 150 voilà mes jeux tout le
monde ne veut pas entrer ensuite dans
les 500 il ya quelques il ya un an il
faut ajouter à cela quelques personnes
français qui était de passage en
touristes parce qu'on venait voir la
famille dans le cas des festivités là
aussi parce qu'on était venu
professionnellement même s'il y avait
une moindre activité dans le cadre du
fait des festivités mais il ya
différents profils donc ce je pense
qu'on priorités vont rentrer
certainement ceux qui étaient là de
passage qui avait pas vocation à rester
à élire et qui ont probablement
peut-être prévu de rentrer plus tôt et
qu'ils vont vraiment envie de rentrer
pour retrouver leur place ici en france
un mandat nombreuses questions qui se
posent aussi est-ce que les conjoints et
conjointes qui ne sont pas de
nationalité française pourront être
rapatriés avec leurs familles c'est de
nombreux quen par exemple un
ressortissant français marié avec une
ressortie elle s'appelle les personnes d
la protection rapprochée
les personnes protégées par dans pas des
ressortissants est normalement ils sont
pris en charge si sont inscrits au
consulat avec une grande question qui
est ce que les autorités chinoises
accepteront évidemment les autorités
françaises essaye de s'en occuper est ce
que les autorités chinoises accepteront
le deuxième point c'est est ce que ces
vols qui vont aller à maurane seront
également chargé d'équipement pour venir
soutenir l'effort en chine la chine
officiellement n'a pas demandé de l'aide
mais en interne on sait que les
autorités chinoises ont demandé donc la
question va notamment se pose est du
japon de la france à voir si on peut
contribuer à porter par exemple des
équipements de protection et délation
c'est la députée faut-il les débats et
si elle le demande il faut voir comment
on peut les deux mois hier soir j'ai été
témoin d'une rencontre avec
l'ambassadeur de chine à paris et à mes
collègues qui se sent circonscription à
une usine qui fabrique des masques et il
ya eu un échange entre eux pour voir
cette usine peut augmenter sa production
et faire une proposition de
d'exportation basque vers l'asie
conclure ce débat qui s'achève
si la france je dis bien
et je n'essaye pas de faire peur vous
posant cette question mais était
confronté à la même chose que la chine
et la région du houran s comparer les
moyens de la coface est ce qu'on aurait
suffisamment de voix la dossiste au
niveau du système de santé les moyens de
voilà d'hospitaliser les gens quel est
le protocole alors sur le plan des ja du
mode de vie de la façon dont nous vivons
nous avons une façon de pouvoir
communiquer que notre population de
l'informer de l'alerté qui est tout à
fait fixé en amont s'est ensuite allumé
mais même pendant là une situation de
crise
ensuite à ma connaissance nous avons
effectivement une organisation sanitaire
extrêmement structurée
le simple fait que nous ayons un samu
qui répondent au téléphone qui permet
d'éviter que les gens se précipitent aux
urgences où se précipitent chez le
médecin c'est fondamental fonds publics
dans ces pays là ça n'existe pas on
convient de mettre en place une
plateforme d'appels téléphoniques mais
un pays moi je viens de singapour il n'y
a pas non plus il n'ya pas de
s'améliorer à transposer on a compris
qu'elle avait quand même été moins
exposés les habitudes les marchés les
animaux là la promiscuité mais malgré
tout y est ce qu'il ya un plan en france
qui existe absolument et est ce que on
ne savait dire arrêtez le métro que ce
qui se passe dans ce plan fait on a des
plans qu'ils existent avec eux des
étapes successives aux fonctions d or
less et qui peuvent aller jusqu'à un
confinement qui ont qu'on essaie de
faire localiser mais tout est adapté
tout est prévu pour et chaque foyer des
équipes qu'ils soient les symboles et
jusqu'au confinement d'un quartier
l'huile et on se réfère eric de radio
vous êtes d'accord on est prêt c'est
c'est eh oui oui je pense qu'il faut
dans ce cas là c'est à dire que les
systèmes de santé français permet de
prendre en charge les malades permet de
faire entrer quand il s'agit de
d'assistance respiratoire seulement bien
sûr des services de réanimation dans
tous les hôpitaux chu et hôpitaux
régionaux et c'est donc sur le système
de santé hôpitaux on est prêt sur le
système de surveillance en santé
publique france fait un travail de
recherche des cas contacts donc là aussi
c'est très très important
donc non je pense qu'il faut rassurer de
ce côté les vaccins en france mais le
vaccin ça fait partie de la recherche
pour l'instant donc on n'aura pas un
média longue pour le courant qu'il
n'existait pas on n'est pas obligés d'en
commander des petits mots sur un autre
risque c'est le risque
au fond de dénigrement de l'autre
vis-à-vis de la chine vous alerter de
cela tout petit peu avant que l'émission
ne commence c'est un risque aussi dans
ce genre de cas de figure sur vidéo
c'est d'abord ça arrive en chine
on est content quand chine si vous venez
d orane on se méfie alors houssin faut
lutter contre ça veut dire
il vient d'asie li lé chinois et des
jaunes ville et dangereux on se retouve
vient quotidien une gaffe c'est non
seulement extrêmement important et puis
il faut rappeler qu'en chine ya une
expression aujourd'hui qui est beaucoup
utilisé segurane vieillot ce qui veut
dire littéralement que que maurane se
battait il faut soutenir bourhane
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut aussi
dire à l'étranger ou radio et zhongshan
à l'est la chine aussi pour merci
beaucoup d'avoir aidé est revenue sur ce
plateau pour débattre de ce problème de
ce virus on va parler à présent de la
réforme des retraites suis sûr que là
vous avez un avis je suis avec eux c'est
un virus citoyen j'ai pas dit ça
un nouveau théâtre d'affrontements s'est
ouvert depuis quelques jours celui de
l'assemblée nationale les députés
d'opposition sont vent debout contre la
volonté du gouvernement d'aller vite et
même très vite ils dénoncent un passage
en force sur un texte à trous
explications ahmed tazir une arrivée
solennelle une quarantaine de députés
les républicains ceints de leur écharpe
tricolore pour réclamer un nouveau
projet de loi de réforme des retraites
dans les couloirs du palais bourbon
l'opposition de droite dénoncent la
précipitation et l'amateurisme du
gouvernement
nous pouvons
accepter de devoir examiner un projet de
loi sur les retraites sans que nous ne
sachions rien de son financement
nous n'avons aucune idée de l'incidence
financière de cette réforme alors même
que les retraites représente plus de 320
milliards d'euros par an 14 % de la
richesse nationale et 25% des impôts des
français ne pouvons pas non plus
accepter l'amateurisme et
l'improvisation permanente dont fait
preuve ce gouvernement sur un sujet
aussi essentiel qui va déterminer
l'avenir de millions de français
l'opposition est en ébullition à gauche
aussi hier déjà le ps la france a
soumises les communistes ont envoyé une
lettre au président de l'assemblée
nationale
il dénonce une démocratie expéditive des
délais l'inadmissible quatre jours entre
la présentation de la loi en conseil des
ministres vendredi dernier et le début
des discussions en commission ce soir je
suis très en colère
je suis très en colère parce que nous
représentons des françaises et des
français dans la diversité de nos
sensibilités et c'est françaises et des
français ils ont le droit à un débat
parlementaire de qualité et ce débat il
ne sera pas de qualité il va être
expéditif et la démocratie expéditif
c'est comme la justice expéditive
ça n'a pas sa place dans notre tradition
républicaine lors des questions au
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est aussi
l'absence de débat parlementaire qui
était pointé du doigt par l'opposition
une procédure accélérée
un dépôt d'amendements limitée à 5 jours
et enfin 29 ordonnance qui prive
l'assemblée d'un débat sur des pans qui
est du projet de loi la procédure
accélérée a rien d'anormal
c'est la réponse du gouvernement je suis
allé vérifier les choses et bien la
procédure accélérée
c'est le cas des usages en matière de
réforme des retraites c'est les deux
dernières réformes qui ont été menées
par les deux dernières majorité qui ont
été faites en procédure accélérée
les discussion dans l'hémicycle sur la
réforme des retraites doivent démarrer
le 17 février c'est qu'il faut aller
vite
l'objectif du gouvernement est qu'elle
soit votée en première lecture avant les
élections municipales
bonsoir célia delavergne merci d'être
sur ce plateau des députés la république
en marche de la drôme et porte parole de
la commission spéciale sur les retraites
qui a pas mal de pain sur la planche
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
bienvenue avoue gilles gosselin député
les républicains de la manche est la
fois sion bienvenue député communiste
des hauts de seine alors que deux
reproches vous fais ton madame la
députée en tout cas à la majorité que
vous représentez démocratie expéditive
procédure accélérée passage en force
avec bon nombre d'ordonnancés signal d'
alerte déjà donné par le conseil d'état
qui dénonce une étude d'impact la tuner
l'absence de régime universel à
proprement parler dans le texte
qu'allez-vous faire allez vous rester
sourd à toutes ces critiques
alors quand on quand on conçoit et qu'on
veut travailler sur un projet de loi sur
la création d'un nouveau système
universel de retraite à points et
concret en fait un nouveau système comme
après la guerre on a créé la sécurité
sociale évidemment ça ouvre un nombre de
débats dans notre société et donc pour
les oppositions qui sont très larges
veille avoir un débat de qualité quand
on regarde les réformes de 2010 et de
2013 il y avait aussi entre 10 et 13
jours entre la présentation en conseil
des ministres et le vote de la loi donc
ce n'est pas inhabituel aujourd'hui
qu'on essaie d'aller là pour l'examiner
moi j'ai commencé mon mandat avec la loi
hulot il y avait moins de quatre mois
entre le moment où il a été présenté en
conseil des ministres et moment nous
l'avons voté de manière définitive donc
fait parlement n'est pas maltraité
le parlement n'est pas maltraité et au
contraire il est alimenté parce que
quand on a une étude d'impact de près de
1000 pages avec un certain nombre de
données sur la base desquels nous
pouvons débattre et ça fait longtemps
que les parlementaires se battent pour
avoir davantage de données je pense
qu'on peut avoir un débat de qualité et
approfondie est la fois si on met quand
même là entre deux il s'est passé
quelque chose c'est à dire que le
conseil d'état a rendu un avis sur une
étude d'impact sur lequel il a un avis
sévère et où ils expliquent qu'ils
impriment d'objectivité et de sincérité
donc nous sommes alertés nous députés
sur des questions précises notamment sur
les projections financières c'est pas
rien quand on est député et aujourd'hui
le conseil d'état nous révèle sa quatre
jours avant le début de l'examen de la
loi en commission
c'est pas anodin sans compter un rien
risques d'insécurité constitutionnel
aujourd'hui c'est une nouvelle
information importante
en plus de la colère exprimée dans le
pays en plus de plein de choses
vous le disiez s'il y a beaucoup de
débats si c'est une loi importante qui
nécessite du débat et c'est le cas
prenons le temps il n'ya pas vous réglez
la médiation a c'est ce que vous
réclamez très concrètes déjà vous le
savez je sais pas si c'est le cas de mon
collègue aux siens mais je me bat aux
côtés de celles et ceux qui demandent le
retrait donc il faut être honnête depuis
le départ je suis mobilisé avec ceux qui
demandent le retrait
aujourd'hui nous n'obtenons pas encore
en tout cas le retrait je suis député je
regarde quelles sont les conditions
d'examen de ce texte et que ce que je
vois c'est que les conditions ne sont
pas réunies et que le constat est en d1
la ville et plusieurs lectures qu'on
renonce à la procédure accélérée par
exemple oui mais tout simplement que le
gouvernement revoie sa copie c'est ce
qu'il ya vraiment ou si on va prendre la
liste des griefs
on va juste se rappeler en deux secondes
que le conseil d'état c'est le
conseiller juridique du gouvernement
voilà quel que soit le gouvernement
c'est le conseiller juridique et bien ce
conseiller juridique qui en quelques
jours a dû rendre un avis ce qu'il a un
qui peut bousculer nous met en garde sur
des risques très grand de difficultés
juridiques premier point sur des
étude d'impact qui sont plutôt indigente
les ordonnances est un autre sujet mais
ça s'ajoute quand même et surtout et
surtout excusé le peut sur les problèmes
les questions de financement
ça concerne quand même 320 milliards par
an c'est quand même pas rien et des
dizaines de millions de personnes
potentiellement et là on va avoir des
deux procédures en fait en réalité
parallèle est complètement déconnecté
une procédure sous cloche entre
guillemets parlementaire pendant quinze
jours ce qui est déjà très court pour
une réforme systémique
c'est une réforme du système ce qui
n'était pas le cas en 2010 et 2013 là on
remet tout à plat vous le dit d'ailleurs
vous même c'est pratiquement le au
lendemain ici ce qui va se passer le
lendemain de la libération
bon bah lendemain de la libération c'est
autre chose que de revoir le système
pourrait on la met plus de temps ça ça
lui faudrait bien plus de procédures
accélérées lecture c'est dur a accéléré
et puis au delà de ça c'est surtout une
concordance des temps on va avoir la
conférence du financement qui va
travailler jusqu'en avril elle est
censée cette conférence nous mettre sur
la table un certain nombre de
propositions
ou alors c'est pas la peine de la réunir
c'est pas la peine d'avoir invité les
syndicats se mettent autour de la table
donc on va nous dans notre coin
bidouiller je ne sais quoi de façon
technique mais sans connaître des
éléments vérifiés au victoire sur un
texte provisoire ce n'est pas du bon
travail logement à part donc re force
cette 1ère force je vois pas ce que ça
peut être d'autre alors vous allez
répondre à la majorité mais j'aimerais
votre regard jean françois kahn c'est
pas la première fois qu'on entend les
oppositions dans cette maison ici au
palais bourbon se plaint de ne pas être
respectés c'est souvent la vème
république
souvent on nous écoute pas ça va trop
vive opposition s'est renforcé le rôle
de l'opposition
l'argument l'opposition qui sont très
contents de la frère mais c'est rare
quand même d'enfants de crusnes seriez
vous avec ce bizouard et
particulièrement dans ce moment là on
traverse la craie la gueule mouvement la
réforme des retraites il y a voilà une
volonté de ce gouvernement d'imposer les
choses non je crois
incontestablement
ce le débat qui a eu lieu dans le pays
la violence du débat montre qu'il ya une
nécessité également d'un vrai débat
parlementaire j'ai toujours pensé que le
débat parlementaire c'est pour éviter
justement la bible du les bains dans la
rue c'est pour ça que j'étais contre la
constitution d'un cinquième république
je suis content de voir que vous venez
sur mes positions et que vous vous
admettez aujourd'hui qu'on a maltraité
le parlement qu'il faudrait revenir à ce
que vous avez critiqué sa part j'ai
vraiment eu un vrai système
parlementaire le maire d'arles arlement
discute le parle le rendement
granulation dont les pouvoirs du
parlement l'a vraiment on aimait la
chambre basse du sous ses allures
indique jeudi je veux dire votre
ralliement
enfin à la nécessité d'un parlement qui
joue ce rôle je l'applaudis j'ai très
content je me bats moi depuis longtemps
là dessus l'autre aspect de la critique
et le plus justifié c'est le fait de
voter la loi avant de connaître
financement toute façon d'une façon
générale baisse qu il ya ce problème là
qui réel il faut reconnaître que la lago
fallait que les communistes ou des
insoumis etc ont toujours leur cohérence
est contre ce type de réforme va d'abord
vous êtes dont la retraite à 60 ans
retrouvait ont toujours été contre ce
type de réforme c'est la structure même
de cette réforme on peut dire d'ailleurs
la même chose et l'extrême droite ils
ont toujours été contre les structures
de la réforme même sont pour la retraite
à 60 ans et cetera pour le reste il ya
quand même une hypocrisie sait pas
exactement le sujet là mais au delà de
la gauche la gauche classique la gauche
socialiste la retraite par points s'est
leurs idées c'est la cfdt c'est les
socialistes et les rocardiens c'est leur
idée depuis des années dit il faut une
récolte une une retraite et tout d'un
coup ils sont content
ils sont compensées leurs droits ils
sont contre la droite c'est vraiment
faut faire un système universel surtout
universel et aucune raison de retraite
etc et tout à coup ils sont positionnés
devant vos yeux
non mais je devrais je dire ça va on va
répondre pourquoi je dis ça parce que
vous me interrogé sur les erreurs qu'on
a faites et qui fait que par exemple
marine le pen peut être lu prénom la
république mais ya pas que ça ou que la
gauche ait retrouvé à 6% ou que la
droite s'est retrouvé à 8%
mais excusez moi il ya un moment où les
jambes oui le comprennent rien ou alors
dit mais je comprends plus rien eux ils
étaient pour mot tant ils sont contre
eux il était pourri sans et est
maintenant il s'en rend compte et ils
disent le contraire est ce que vous
imaginez alors plus la responsabilité du
pouvoir qui n'a pas su défendre sa
retraite les gens n'y comprend rien dans
tout ça si vous voulez entre les avances
de la bouche mêmes raisons la droite
c'est la communication absurde et
délétère du pouvoir en effet ben oui ben
voilà il y aura des débats d abstention
massive une extrême droite a regagné sa
cellule et puis on reviendra sur la
question du financement et du calendrier
on vous fait un procès en cohérence on
nous fait un procès incohérences nous on
est effectivement pour revoir le système
des retraites on s'en est jamais caché
on veut un système équitable certes et
ça pouvait être l'objectif poursuivi par
le gouvernement n'en voit bien qu'au fil
du temps il ya plus de régimes spéciaux
nous dit on met des régimes spécifiques
je suis désolé demain à l'opéra de paris
on continuera à partir à 42 ans j'ai le
contrôleur aérien il y aura encore
d'autres éléments à la ratp on n'a pas
remis à plat la sncf on n'a pas remis à
plat et cetera donc en réalité on a plus
de régimes spéciaux mais spécifique
agressé loin on n'a pas été assez loin
donc c'est pas cohérent pour la fonderie
y est a 65 ans et est au et nous on l'a
clairement annoncé une retraite à 64
et puis peut-être 65 donc on est très
cohérent là dessus mais au delà
vous voyez il faudra dire les
auditionnant les obsessions
quelques différences quand ma tête mais
au-delà de ça y est on est on est
ensemble pour respecter les droits de
l'opposition murray mais devrait se
retrouver sur la l'incohérence à ne pas
présenter un projet qui peut avoir sa
cohérence
admettons je veux bien même si ce n'est
pas celle que je défends et le
financement vous donne je donne la
parole à la fois si l'on sait c'est sûr
mais là vous avez la question du
financement tout ce que vous êtes
plusieurs à l'avoir abordée je crois
qu'il faut pas confondre deux choses il
ya le financement du futur système
universel et ça c'est très clairement
expliquées dans la loi c'est le principe
d'un âge déquilibre c'est tout le débat
qu'on a eue avant sur lequel elle peut
revenir et qui est très clair qui n'est
pas inscrit par ordonnance qui écrit de
manière très claire dans la loi comment
on finance le futur système de retraite
universel c'est qu'à ce qu'on demande et
c'est la manière dont le choix de nous
avoir donné moi mais les fumées mais ont
créé vous et soutenons et élèves
déquilibre dans la loi mais que ce sont
les syndicats qui le fixe en que les
députés puissent en débattre
il ya quand même un gars tu sers un
problème le projet de loi il définit une
gouvernance qui allie démocratie
politique et démocratie sociale et qui
permet à une caisse le conseil
d'administration de la future caisse dur
du système de retraite universel
aujourd'hui de définir justement fameuse
âge dansante ce fameux jeu d'équilibré
sauf rien c'est une ordonnance d'ici on
prendra le marché libre a nagé en lait
beurre dans la loi ce que ce qui à ce
que la conférence de financement doit
faire c'est définir les modalités de
retour à l'équilibré en 2027
c'est à dire à court terme il ya bien
dans ce projet de loi est souvent on
essaye de nous faire croire que c'est la
même chose
quelque chose de très clair inscrit dans
la loi sur le système à long terme et
ses principes et donc court terme
comment on arrive comment on revient à
l'équilibré d'ici 2027 et le choix que
nous avons fait et qui interroge le
conseil d'état et dont acte et dont nous
prenons connaissance c'est comment on
concilie démocratie politique démocratie
sociale c'est le choix qu'on a fait
dévier deux ans et demi ils sont emparés
des premiers avec les partenaires
sociaux pour qu à l'assemblée le débat
prenne sa place et le débat a énormément
progressé en deux ans et demi on l'a vu
encore récemment sur les droits
familiaux avec l'unsa sur la question de
la pénibilité avec les scènes d'été qui
étaient des choses qui n'étaient pas
forcément dans le rapport que
monsieur le vent à wimmenau ça c'est
pour la réponse sur le financement vous
pourrez discuter voire amendé la notion
d'âge déquilibre sur le calendrier
pourquoi elle est si vite ça fait 2-0
gratier culyer nos oppositions eu le
temps de présenter leur propre
contre-projet donc quand on dit on n'a
pas le temps de travailler avec eux dès
que sera l'élection présidentielle
parenthèse jan 2010 cinq comprend pas la
poudre assez ans d'histoire ce que je
veux dire c'est que vous avez chacun
chez vous et c'est normal dans vos
groupes parlementaires des spécialistes
de la question et que donc étudier ce
projet de loi aujourd'hui dans le délai
alors que ça fait deux ans qu'on en
parle qu'on a une concertation publique
c'est tout à fait raisonnable c'est nous
faire croire quelque chose au nom de la
forme
vous ne voulez pas qu'on aille sur le
fond et vous ne voulez pas de cette
réforme non nous allons la faire mais la
fatigue pourrait vois je trouve à quel
point quelque part la question même du
financement est une sorte de prétextes
moi je ne crois absolument pas que
l'objet de votre projet de loi soit la
question du financement et d'une
incapacité à financer les retraites ça
c'est quelque part le prétexte qu est
aujourd'hui présenté aux françaises et
aux français vous avez plein de moyens
aujourd'hui de financer les retraites
par vous aujourd'hui c'est un prétexte
cette question du financement
il ya par exemple et même le rapport du
conseil d'orientation des retraites le
dis vous créez vous même des difficultés
de financement sur les retraites par
exemple en supprimant un grand nombre de
fonctionnaires et ça c'est très présent
dans le rapport qui a été fait par le
conseil d'orientation des retraites le
cor moi ce que je crois c'est qu'il ya
une vision de société que vous avez du
mal à assumer d'abord vous considérez
que eh bien il faut travailler plus
longtemps mais aussi que cette idée d'un
collectif solidaire de manière concrète
qui est extrêmement présent dans la
conception des retraites après la
libération
vous n'en voulez pas un peu comme vous
souhaitez prolonger
l'ubs et risation de la société où
quelque part chacun et comptable de ses
points de ses revenus où il se vend vous
êtes sur cette conception là aujourd'hui
dans la réforme des retraites que vous
mettez à répondre
sont déjà menés 9 6 pour ça qu'elle est
bâclée et quand je regarde rien que sur
la situation puisque c'est ma commission
de l'éducation celle des professeurs mes
rêves nice elle n'a aucun sens cette
étude d'impact vous vous faites une
projection se dit d'ailleurs le point
d'indicé regardons jeu de réserve il est
gelé depuis des années donc vous ne
pouvez pas aborder une question de
financement sur laquelle on peut avoir à
se prononcer alors même que ce que vous
proposez ici n'a aucun fondement
aujourd'hui et même sur les années à
venir puisque vous pouvez pas vous
engager sur le dégel
nous avons voulu donner un maximum de
gages aujourd'hui aux enseignants et aux
chercheurs vous l'avez vu vous même ils
sont très inquiets ce que nous avons
fait dans les courbes à leur demande
nous avons mis dans cette loi dégage
aujourd'hui il y a effectivement un
risque souligné par le conseil d'état
d'instabilité juridique
ça ne nous empêchera pas de continuer
leur donner des le conseil d'état pour
ce faire il nous regarde pas ce que
c'est compliqué dit que la
revalorisation des enseignants ne doit
pas figurer dans ce texte la
revalorisation des enseignants n'est pas
totalement sécurisé on sait mois ci en
marché d'un four en 2030 c'est moi je ne
le souhaite pas par exemple en mai deux
façons ils ne peuvent pas et vous le
voyez bien que ce sujet là pour relancer
une mobilisation d'hier et beaucoup
d'enseignants dans la rue nan parce
qu'il ne s'agit pas de la parole
politique que nous portons il s'agit de
sujets juridiques
aujourd'hui est ce que cette ce que le
conseil ne nous dit pas il ne faut pas
de loi de programmation il lui dit qu'
il ne faut pas écrire faire une
injonction à l'état en le demandant de
faire une loi de programmation cette loi
mais cette fois programmation le
ministre blanc coeur s'est engagé à la
présenter d'ici alors on va pas vous
mettre d'accord là-dessus j'aurais quand
même dit un mot de votre livre dense
dans ces débats non mais c'est important
parce que vous regardez ces débats se
jouer et j'ai regardé parce que vous
avez au fond cette ambition dans votre
livre de remonter aux origines de nos
erreurs qui sont des erreurs collectives
vous considérez que la droite n'a pas
fait son bras d'inventaire la gauche ne
l'a pas fait non plus
l'extrême gauche ne l'a pas fait et
qu'au fond c'est parce qu'on ne sait pas
pourquoi donc commet des erreurs ou
qu'on alimente voilà d'une certaine
façon les extrêmes est ce que vous vous
êtes très sévère avec au fond les deux
les deux parties qui ont gouverné
les années précédentes moins sévère avec
macro pourquoi ah non je suis pas mal
c'est parce que c'est pas le sujet je la
mets dans votre jeu vient votre livre
puisque les lieux au contraire c'est à
dire les erreurs coq et que vous avez
commis en fait que la gauche et faudrait
que la droite c'est et maquereau est
arrivé au caire et macro y arriver au
pouvoir dont je veux pas dire vous avez
commis d'accord qui vous avez fait
arriver grâce à ça c'est le prochain
tournage en page d'erreur de maquereaux
jeudi même si on a rarement autant
commis en si peu de temps mais je veux
dire c'est pas le sujet de le lan a dit
non parce que on a si je vous avais dit
il y à il ya quatre ans cinq ans que en
effet une victoire de marine le pen
c'est pas le plus probable je ne crois
pas que c'est le plus probable mais
n'est pas impossible d'envoyer 10 c'est
inconcevable il est fou ce mec
aujourd'hui c'est possible
d'accord il suffit pas de dire et de
faire comme certains le fascisme ne
passera pas mais quelle erreur il a
fallu comme être arrivé là et ceux qui
ont confisqué la façon de lutter contre
le front national
vous ne posez pas de question pour vous
vous mettez pas sur la table tel qu'on
s'est trompé le le parti socialiste
benoît hamon paparazzi au pouvoir la
diabolisation et là il à l'assemblée il
a le président de la république les
régions il a des départements il séduit
cas le plus d'argent parce que c'est le
parti principal si pour ça on n'a jamais
vu ça jamais même si louis philippe
même si napoléon iii n'a jamais vu ça
vous les avez entendu dire mais quelle
erreur
mais quelle erreur on a pu commettre
pour arriver ça la droite c'est la même
chose même de ne plus être au second
tour faire 8 % etc
même quand on dit rachida dati
formidable et à 19 ou 20 % biais du
chirac vous 50 et quelle erreur on a
commis ses logiciels
on n'est pas en version ne les voit pas
c'est qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde comme
les erreurs je parle moi même de mes
erreurs dans le livre débute bien sûr
mais il faut les regarder enfin si on
les regarde pas enfin même le parti
communiste parti comme il est très bon
candidat par exemple aux européennes
franchement très bons mais qui fait 2,5
dont cosy mais comment avec un bon
candidat
un mécontentement social 2,5 vous avez
entendu s'interroger quelles sont les
erreurs qu'on a commis six mois j'étais
sûr que diraient oui mais c'est pas vrai
absolument pas j'ai interpellé après les
européennes et avec d'autres à une
grande réunion pour dire quelles sont
les erreurs françois commencent à
reconnaître un imaginaire avait dit
jeudi que dans sa tour à tour soutenir
les choses conduit là dessus faut
s'interroger exemple il ya eu une
pétition d'intellectuels pour soutenir
la guerre d'irak à croyait avec des
intérêts importants genre c'est la
démocratie ce qui est formidable c'est
très bien catastrophe absolue
allaient ils n'ont pas reconnu le
résultat c'est qu'il ya eu la même
intellectuels ont fait une pétition pour
soutenir un quart de livre droit dans le
mur notre cas voilà de nos erreurs et du
refus de les reconnaître mais c'est
aussi une forme d'appel au sursaut 1 il
faut pas mon jour toi c'est surtout un
appel à reconduire faire un débat a
accepté un débat et il ne sera pas
accepté je vous fais le pari que les
gens que j'interpelle n'accepterons pas
le débat aller ou alors en tout cas on
peut leur on pourra le tenir ici sur été
récoltés en l2 boys pour était avec son
fils beau et cela parce que je devrai
qu'on garde un tout petit peu de temps
avant de claude clôturer cette émission
pour parler de paris paris les
municipales vous en parliez à l'instant
on va accueillir tout de suite défini
des pierres
[Musique]
figurez vous restez avec nous figurez
vous que ce qui se passe dans la
campagne de villani ce qui se passe dans
la campagne de griveaux a des incidences
ici à l'assemblée nationale bonsoir
stéphanie alors l'exclusion de cédric
villani va être discutée demain soir au
bureau exécutif de la république en
marche et depuis l'annnonce de sa
probable sanction exclusion rien ne va
plus dans la majorité
énormément de député explique qu'il ne
faut surtout pas aller se lancer dans
cette logique d'exclusion
oui les boucles le télégramme des
députés de la majorité chauffe depuis
dimanche ce serait une gigantesque
conneries d'exclure villani ce n'est pas
dans l'adn dans marche exclure villani
c'est le contraire de ce sur quoi on
s'est construit on n'est pas une cour de
récré il est méchant je le vire en
marche est devenus plus sectaires qu'une
section du ps de très nombreux marcheurs
de la première heure vous l'aurez
compris ne veulent pas entendre parler
d'exclusion et surtout pas maintenant
il aurait fallu l'exclure dès le début
peste un cadre de la majorité
jean-françois cesarini figure de l' aile
gauche lui ne dit pas autre chose
l'exclure aujourd'hui ça ne veut rien ça
ne peut que nous fragiliser et entamer
l'unité du groupe
ce serait contre-productif bien débuté
plus légitimistes et oui parce que si on
exclut cédric villani du mouvement et du
groupe alors est-ce qu'il faut exclure
la trentaine de députés qui le soutient
même s'ils ne sont pas sur ces listes et
les autres députés qui sont candidats
aux municipales
ailleurs en france candidats dissidents
on les exclut aussi évidemment ça va
finir par faire beaucoup de
parlementaires au moins au groupe en
marche
en tout cas il y en a une qui a pris les
devants c'est paula forte ça l'une est
député les est plus engagé avec villa ni
les têtes de liste dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris et ce matin elle
annoncé qu'elle partage on annonce
aujourd'hui mon départ de la république
en marche je viens d'envoyer un courrier
à mes collègues pour expliquer les
raisons de mon départ je reste mérite et
non inscrits pour l'instant je me
concentre dans ma campagne dans le 19e
mais je crois qu'il ya la place dans à
l'assemblée nationale pour un groupe
écologique et solidaire
alors est-ce que d'autres députés
marcheurs ont envie de la suivre et
quittait le groupe
alors ce qui est clair c'est ce que ça
s'agite à nouveau en coulisses depuis ce
week-end du côté des députés de l'ailé
gauche
la majorité du côté aussi des marcheurs
qui sont déjà parties et qui voudrait
attirer d'autres anciens collègues pour
faire un groupe écologiste et solidaire
dont parlait pour la forte ça bon pour
le moment rien n'est fait loin de là
al'inverse il faut savoir que la
déclaration tonitruante de cédric
villani dimanche à sa sortie de l'elysée
a même gêner certains de ses soutiens et
grands sont vice président de
l'assemblée nationale est très mal à
l'aise
jean-michel fauvergue l'ancien patron du
raid lui a carrément lâché le candidat
gilles rangerait dans le rang voilà
gilles legendre lui et le patron des
députés fait le maximum pour retenir ses
troupes
il n'aime pas trop les exclusions il
essaye de garder tous les apparentés
avec lui parce qu'il sait que la barre
fatidique de la majorité absolue
approché il était 314 au groupe en 2017
ils ne sont plus trois sont 2 le seuil
de la majorité est à 2 189 députés
on ne peut pas se permettre d'avoir une
hémorragie des thunes chef de groupe
sinon le modem sera en position et
l'hémorragie tout de suite maintenant ça
paraît très bien très très bien parce
que comme ils nous ont foutu un système
électoral le plus injuste du monde
on avait un 4 pour cent des voix on peut
avoir 65 % a débuté que ce soit les
remarques de servian scrutin uninominal
majoritaire à the border de fret
relationnel a presque l'âge que vous
croyez un peu trop lié selon lui ce
n'est pas une foire régionale mrc dans
le pays sont des bénefs un démon gratter
mission est urgent d'en bas on va avoir
le pluralisme qui sauva son de fo
s'engagent encore fela les avoirs du
projet qui veut se reconstruire la belle
soirée sur s&p et à demain bon courage à
paris
[Musique]